but above all my thanks goes to the
residents of sheffield hallam who have
once again shown their confidence in me
and I'm very very grateful and humbled
by their confidence in me I know of
course that many voters did not support
me this time and had done so previously
and my message to them is very simple is
the greatest honour of my political life
to have served this wonderful part of
this wonderful city and I will always
work diligently in Westminster on all of
their behalf on behalf of all
communities and all families across
sheffield hallam turning to the national
picture it is now painfully clear that
this has been a cruel and punishing
night for the Liberal Democrats the
election has profound implications for
the country it also obviously has
profound implications for the Liberal
Democrats and I will be seeking to make
further remarks about the implications
of this election both for the country
and for the party that I lead and for my
position in the Liberal Democrats when I
make remarks to my colleagues in the
Liberal Democrats later this morning
when I return to Westminster thank you
very much